-I'm so, so happy you are here.
-Thanks for having me.
-And I want to start
by saying there was a moment --
I've been a big fan
of your music for long time.
But there was a moment
where I felt a real connection
with you that I never felt
before which is,
you were on "American Idol"
and Kelly Clarkson sang a song,
"Piece by Piece."
-Mnh. Yeah.
-And it was -- she cried,
Jennifer Lopez cried,
you cried the hardest.
-Well, yeah.
I don't know if the hardest,
but --
-Except for me at home watching.
-You got it, too.
[ Laughter ]
-I cried so hard.
And my wife was making
so much fun of me.
-How so?
-She was like,
"You're the worst.
Anything emotional, you cry."
And I'm like, "Hey,
your boyfriend Keith Urban" --
she's a big fan --
"is also crying.
Let me off the hook."
Did you -- did you --
were you aware
as you were listening to that
like, "Oh, man, this is on TV."
-Right. It was everything.
-Yeah.
-It was the song.
It was the situation.
She's pregnant. It's like --
-Yeah.
-It was amazing song.
-There's a lot going on
in that song.
-Yeah, I was very jealous you
got to be there for it because
I thought that was pretty great.
-Well, evidentially,
you experienced it at home.
-I did. I just want you to know
that we were going through
something very similar.
So, hey, you are about to
go on a 58-city tour.
-Yeah.
-That must be exciting.
-Yeah, I'm looking forward
to it.
New music
and getting out touring.
I love touring.
-Is it great?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah. Yeah.
-How's your -- I know you --
obviously,
you got a couple kids now.
You got a family.
Has your touring schedule
changed the way you do it?
-A little bit maybe.
Go out on the weekends,
Thursday, Friday, Saturday,
sort of three shows.
Maybe a midweek one
occasionally.
But I pretty much play shows
and go home,
play shows and go home.
-Your girls are 7 and 9.
-7 and 9.
-It's obviously happening
during the summer,
a good chunk of this tour.
Will they -- Do they
like to go out?
Is that an age where they
like to see you onstage?
-They love the tour bus.
-Okay.
-They love the bunks
and the whole thing in the bus.
So -- but, you know,
I have catering at my shows.
Mom has like craft services
at her set.
-Yeah.
-So it's always battle
for who's got the better food.
-Gotcha.
[ Laughter ]
So it's not really like,
"Oh, my God.
Our mom is Nicole Kidman.
She's this an amazing actor.
And our dad is Keith Urban."
-Definitely not.
-They don't care about that?
-No, definitely not.
-They're just like,
"Who has the macaroni
and cheese?"
-We had -- She was at a show
of mine one time.
She must have been 6.
A Sunday, she was 6.
And we're backstage
and I'm like --
And they had stayed up.
Normally they go to bed early.
You know?
So they're up.
We go onstage.
And I said, "do you want
to come see me play?"
She goes, "Do I have to?"
[ Laughter ]
Just really keeping it real.
-It's also -- I love that
what's keeping her from going to
see you at a giant arena
is like,
"Dad, it's just --
there is a bus."
-Yeah.
-Totally.
-Yeah like, "I'd love to go.
But I got this bus
to do stuff on."
-Absolutely.
We played stagecoach
on the weekend and they wanted
to hang in the bus
instead of come see Dad play.
So I get it.
-Alright, that's alright.
-I totally get it.
-I'm glad that happens
for all dads.
I'm sure when you have a 7-
and 9-year-old,
that's happening around
the world.
And your wife, Nicole,
sings backup one of the songs
on this album?
-Yeah, on "Female." Yes.
-And is it hard to convince
her to do that?
-Yes.
-Oh, it is? Okay.
[ Laughter ]
-Yes.
It will be like trying to get me
to do a scene in something.
It's not my comfort level
at all.
We have a studio at the house.
And it was just one of those
times when I was recording
that song "Female,"
and I thought,
if there ever was a song
for her, that's the perfect one.
And she was home, so --
-Oh, that's great.
-I dragged her down to do it.
-So at least there,
that's the privacy of your home.
But you actually got her
to come up onstage with you
in Nashville recently.
-Reluctantly she did, yes.
-Okay.
-And well, what was happened
was, I was talking about
this song called
"Parallel Line," which is
on my new album and --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you.
-Got some fans right there.
-So cut a long story short,
wasn't planning on singing
the song.
I was playing solo. And I was
going to do some other song.
And I'm talking about this song
to try and avoid singing it,
this particular song.
And from the back of the people,
I hear this woman go,
"Play the song."
You know?
And of course, it's Nic.
And I'm like, ugh! You know?
So I thought,
"Well, I'll just say to her,
'You come up and sing it with
me, and I'll do the song.'
and that would be the end
of the song. And I can move on."
And I -- some time went by,
and I saw her slinking slowly
up towards the stage.
And she came up.
-Oh, that's great.
-To her credit, she came up
and played it with me.
-That must have been
a real thrill for everybody
in the house that night.
-Me most of all, yes.
-What is a recording studio
in your house like?
What is the scene like
when you go to
Keith Urban's recording studio?
-It's pretty chill. We built the
studio with these big windows.
It was supposed to be
an underground studio,
which is a whole other story.
But it's aboveground,
has big windows,
lots of natural light coming in.
And I just -- I feed off
that energy really, really well.
This record "Graffiti U"
is very buoyant.
It's very up. And I think
part of that is from that.
-It would have been completely
different album if you had...
-Oh, yeah.
-...recorded it underground.
-Yes, underground.
Quite literally, yes.
-Yeah.
-Yes, yes.